Alex has a physical body break
and a spiritual, emotional break
where all of these
shackles come down.
Tell me what’s in the book
Maggie.
You don’t like me.
You’ve never liked me.
That’s not true.
Which part?
That I’ve never liked you.
Marcia Gay is
absolutely incredible.
These two women laid it all out
and It was this power
that Maggie Brener
had over Alex.
This little bit of power that
could in fact destroy her career
Alex is just trying
to survive, desperately.
It’s a little late to be
storming into my hotel room.
Now what, what is it you
even want?
Marcia feels so bad
being so mean to me.
We both end a scene where we’re
not nice to each other
we said, I’m so sorry.
My interest is in trying to do
right by your daughter.
They’re going to try and make it
seem like she had problems
long before she got to UBA.
What kind of problems?
Cory’s wrestling with
protecting Hannah, protecting
the name of a victim who can’t
speak for herself
and with the specter of Fred
hanging over him saying,
"I’m gonna out you
at any point."
--- which if it was uncovered, it
would be a problem for his
relationship with Bradley
That fact that Cory is able to
navigate that in some way is,
I think, quite interesting.
Billy is so good this season.
He’s in this position of power,
he has all these
feelings about Bradley.
They’re so complicated,
there’s so much at stake.
Billy is one of the most
fascinating minds alive,
and brings things to this
character that just,
I mean you watch every take
and you’re just
in awe of what comes out of him.
I don’t blink when he is acting.
I didn’t want to be this person.
I didn’t want to hurt anyone.
I didn’t want people to think
I was the kind of person that
could hurt someone.
In that scene Steve Carell
just moved everybody on set
and I think it’s really a
testament to how
incredible an actor he is.
There’s a wonderful dynamic
between Mitch and Paola
because she was not a part of
his previous world.
He feels like he can probably
speak in a more unfettered
pure way with her.
So she’s a wonderful vessel for
us to see what exactly is
Mitch purely thinking.
Mitch realizes that he did
terrible things and
that there were real
consequences for his actions
and that he really hurt people.
Paola asks him the questions
that he’s asking himself
on the inside and she’s forcing
him to confront these issues
and answer those questions.
I’m just pretty damaged.
I know.